We can also write each of these square roots and each of these cubed roots in
another way. We can use a fractional exponent or a rational exponent to write
them. Remember that the index here for these square roots is a 2. So using this
index of 2 and this power of 1, we can rewrite the square root of 4 as 4 to the
1 half. The square root of 25 can be written as 25 to the 1 half. And the
square root of 81 can be written as 81 to the 1 half. So notice that this
fractional exponent really represents a radical, and in this case a square
root. We can write the cube root of 8 as 8 to the 1 3rd, and we can rewrite the
cubed root of 125 as 125 to the 1 3rd power. The same is true for 343. So, what
does each part of the fractional exponent represent? Does the numerator
represent a power, the index of the root, a square root, or a reciprocal? And
what does the denominator represent? Is it a power, an index of the root, a
square root, or a reciprocal? Use these same words for each of the answer
choices over here, and then pick one for this blank, and one for this blank.
Good luck.